aucune idée
dans ce film, nous voulions en quelque sorte le
dépouiller et nous voulions nous amuser davantage,
vous savez, je suis tyka, j'ai eu exactement la même
idée et nous disions tous les deux que
Ragnarok installé essayait d'avoir plus d'
attitude ragnaroks une sorte de nouveau cycle
sur la vie du monde tous les royaumes
de l'univers c'est la destruction de
l'ancien et la renaissance des nouveaux réseaux
vraiment excitant pour moi surprise ce
sera tellement amusant la façon dont j'ai abordé
cela est de le reconstruire dans un  nouvelle façon de regarder
super mec en temps opportun je pense que c'est juste
un mélange parfait pour là où ce personnage et cette
histoire devaient aller vous savez différents
costumes différentes armes différents
acteurs ou personnages pour travailler ou vous donner une
énergie différente
Thor est dans une crise il n'est jamais retourné à
Asgard pour  réclamer le trône il voulait l'
aventure quand nous le récupérons il est à
la fin de cette recherche de lui-même quand
il veut être survécu district je dirais
les chances d'un
million pour financer vous savez que je voulais
emmener les gens faire un tour et injecter du
som  e comédie en elle une aventure qui fait
rire les gens tout au long du chemin mais
a aussi un spectacle et des trucs qui font
passer le temps aux gens c'est un combattant
vous